what's your exercise routine just to
linger on that what do you how much do
you curl I mean what are we talking
about
here that's all I do at the gym so I
just I I I my my routine um you know on
a good day I do about half an hour of
cardio and I do about 45 minutes of
weightlifting resistance training of
some kind mostly weights I have a
trainer who you know I love um who
pushes me and which is really helpful
you know I'll be like uh he'll
say uh Jeff J you could can we go up on
that we a little bit and I'll think
about it and I'll be like no I don't
think so and he'll be he'll look at me
and say yeah I think you
can and of course he's right so it's
awful to have somebody push you a little
bit but almost every day you do that I I
do almost every day I do a little bit of
cardio and a little bit of weightlifting
and um I rotate I do a pulling day and a
pushing day and a leg day it's all
pretty standard
stuff